dire bonsoir
est-ce que vous pouvez le vous lever
voulait déjà fait au début donc vous
pouvez recommencer
vous vous tourner d'un côté ou l'autre
et vous rencontrez le regard d'un voisin
vous poser maintenant vos deux mains sur
ses épaules
non je ne me souviens plus du nom du bar
perdu et vous nous c'était bien
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous rasseoir est ce que
vous avez senti le grand frisson de
l'amour oui est ce que certaines
personnes n'ont pas senti parce que vous
pouvez vous faire rembourser 1
c'est à dire depuis 2025 tedx a mis en
place un le jura logiciel dame cerise à
sion donc si vous n'êtes pas à côté de
quelqu'un qui vous fait le grand fauve
ou déclenché le grand frisson vous fait
rembourser vous ayez compris on va
parler du futur de l'amour
il se trouve qu'en 2017 j'ai écrit le
dico du futur de l'amour un ouvrage
exceptionnel
pourquoi parce que j'ai été en 2031 et
j'ai rencontré tu refus et eurent fait
ils m'ont raconté leur histoire
le premier temps leur rencontre ils ont
d'abord à montrer leur encontre
il se trouve que leurs arrière grands
parents s'étaient rencontrés au p'tit
bal du samedi soir et c'était bien et
c'était bien leurs parents se sont
rencontrés au boulot et s'est il bien
laure leurs parents seuil à se
rencontrer dans leurs parents se sont
rencontrés sur un site de rencontres
c'était vers 2015 2020 et c'était
vraiment pas bien
il fallait là à ce moment là photo life
et sa vie alors le principe c'est je
mesure 1 mètre 20 mais j'étais grand
allez je mets un mètre 80 un jeu pèse 73
kg avec les avec les sandales donc la
safra 49 kg alors question études
d'accord gernez vielles à deux bacs
âgées deux bacs à fleurs un bac à sable
donc je note bac +5 ou souffrait aussi
de deux tonnes des rites 1 à lui il est
un vrai manque à nos méfaits un peu trop
jogging et très king et on sait que ça
oxygène parfois mal le cerveau en pis
elle une bombe ou enfin bon dormir avec
son gilet jaune c'est tout de même pas
top qui ont plus de salles collectionne
les chats il fallait aussi de temps en
temps faire appel à un rupteur dégagé 17
rouleau en relou en même temps on avait
peut-être des fois un petit peu dire
voilà c'est un peu beaucoup
et puis il fallait aussi tentant à
investir dans un fantôme amour pour
avoir un peu de tranquillité pourquoi
à ce moment là la lgo matching étaient
lamentables
pas tout simplement parce que
l'algorithme été nourris avec des
données de très mauvaise qualité
uniquement des données d'âge de taille
du lieu géographique d'études enfin rien
d'intéressant
heureusement quelques années plus tard
c'est plus exactement quand ces mais les
gaffes à son arrivée et leur la caisse
qu'ils ont mis dans l'algorithme toutes
les conversations tous les sms tous les
instants à tous les to les sweep
ils ont rajouté aussi le génome résultat
des courses
qu'est ce qui s'est passé le le snalgol
matching c'était à 99%
ça a changé beaucoup de choses ce moment
là quand on a pu avoir
on pouvait en trois clics rencontrer
l'âme soeur
d'abord la première chose très positive
suppression de la solitude
quel que soit quel que soit l'âge si on
était gros maigres handicapés tout en
trois clics ont rencontré l'âme soeur
plus besoin aussi on met à la poubelle
tous les supras amour toutes ces pilules
qui efface les peines de coeur on a une
pet shop
alors vous savez comment ça marche la
paix choc c'est un peu comme un
détecteur de métaux et puis bon voilà on
va vers l'âme soeur et temps en temps ça
fait bip bip bip c'est pas mal dans le
train on a aussi assisté à ce moment là
à la multiplication des relations
éphémères et surtout ça a été le bund et
effi mariage des mariages à durée
déterminée six mois 18 mois au plus tôt
18 mois ce qui pour faire la fête à
chaque fois et puis il ya eu aussi des
mariages longue durée alors là c'est les
couples sont aidés par les dates allofs
alors le principe des data loss c1 c'est
simple moins quinze petits bouquets de
fleurs un petit resto -30 week-end à
venise - 95
là il faut mettre le paquet dix jours
aux îles marquises
selmi deuxième temps aussi m'ont parlé
du refus et eurent fait de l'évolution
de leurs peuples
il se trouve que leurs grands-parents
ont construit comme tous les grands
parents d'ailleurs de leur palais ont
construit leur vie sur la possession au
peu là le principe de construction de
vie c'était on possède un petit
appartement un plus grand de maison est
aux deux on possède une voiture une plus
grande voiture de voiture est ou le
principe de la possession à partir de et
la vie amoureuse était aussi basé sur la
possession c'est à dire la femme
mon mari mon copain mon chien mes
enfants toute l'histoire à partir de
2015 2020 au moment de l'arrivée des
plateformes collaboratives ça change
on est plus sur la possession mais on
est de plus en plus sur lusage à quoi
bon h avoir une maison à la campagne
s'ils ont deux clics on peut avoir les
quinze jours qui nous font au signal à
quoi bon avoir un posséder une voiture
s'il y en a une en bas qui arrive en un
clic et au fil du temps on assiste aussi
à l'évolution du couple qui en phase
avec cette évolution sociétale cpd jade
depuis 2015 2020 on le voit apparaître
se dire les couples sont peuvent passer
beaucoup de temps ensemble sans pour
autant avoir cette notion de mon copain
ma copine et puis on voit par exemple
dans certains pays
l'arrivée du mariage des troupes dire
des couples à 3 en colombie et au brésil
ça s'est passé vers les 2016 à peu près
donc pu refus et eurent fait qu'est ce
qu'ils font ico l'amour alors que
l'amour et quand on en parlait en 2018
il y avait une notion un petit peu
négative on avait l'impression c'était
une notion de partouzes peu mais c'est
pas du tout ça c'est à dire l'évolution
du c la reconstruction du couple en
phase avec la société
sans cette notion de propriété
troisième temps la famille bien sûr que
des choses ont changé 1 quand j'ai
rencontré du refus et eurent fait alors
tout comprendre un peu l'évolution est
ce qu'ils m'ont expliqué il fallait
revenir un peu en arrière il fallait
revenir en en 2004 construire des
premiers décryptage du génome des
milliards de dollars coûte très très
cher 2018 quelques années plus tard ça
coûte 200 euros
deuxième chose 2016 un christ peur casse
9 derrière ce mot un peu complet c'est
un nouveau côté plutôt génétique 6-2
voilà couteau génétique à partir de là
on commence les modifications génétiques
et entre autres les modifications
génétiques de l'embryon humain
on commence toujours pour le meilleur
le principe c'est un des parents qui
disent tous qu'ils sont atteints de
gênes un porteur de maladies graves
on supprime ces gènes et on permet aux
parents d'avoir des enfants
et puis au fil du temps où s'aperçoit
qu'en chine on commence aussi à bricoler
un peu le génome humain
et puis bon en 2030 ben je tue refus et
turf est figé nos fente c'est-à-dire et
construisent le patrimoine génétique de
leur bébé
alors c'est des journées un peu
compliqué car sophie blond brun cerveau
de maïs à nous de nous nommons celui là
peut-être pas il faut pas exagérer et
puis aussi les cinq doigts aussi doivent
à ce que la wii les kardashian et ils
ont programmé des des bébés ainsi doit
donc ça devient des bébés tendance donc
là on a une espèce de dévolution et on
arrive au niveau sociétal a vraiment des
choses qui sont assez graves
la première c'est qu'on a des bébés de
riches et des pays pauvres
les bébés driessche ils ont plus de
maladies parce que bien entendu on a
supprimé tous
les jeunes de maladies graves 1 enfin
supprimé et puis ben ils ont aussi un
autre avantage c'est que les assurances
qui voit qu'eux ils sont pas les
assurances sont moins fort puisqu'ils
sont porteurs de maladies moins de
maladies et puis il ya les bébés des
pauvres qui sont des bébés bio des fois
100% naturel donc ça c'est la première
crise
la deuxième chose très problématique
c'est le fait que tout d'un coup toute
la société et toute la famille était
basée sur la la ligne et le sang la
transmission du sang la transmission des
jeunes à partir de ce moment là il ya
débat parce que le principe de base de
cette évolution n'existe plus on peut on
conçoit des bébés avec 3 à 4 par an on a
des bébés conçus dans des exoterres us
donc je peux vous dire qu'en 2031 quand
j'ai été il y avait un débat très
important sur l'évolution de la famille
et les règles à mettre en place dans la
famille donc c'est tout ce que m'ont
raconté un tueur future fête mais le
futur de l'amour ça commence aussi
aujourd'hui
alors vous pouvez peut-être vous relever
c'est de nouveau échangé
[Musique]
merci c'était tout juste après
[Applaudissements]